[Musique]
bonsoir à tous excellentes années 2020 à
toutes et à tous bienvenue pour un
nouveau numéro du 7-8 échos le magazine
consacré aux entreprises et à l'économie
locale tout de suite
le sommaire recruter de manière
innovante le site thalès d'elancourt a
organisé une session de recrutement au
palais des sports candidats et
recruteurs ont participé à une
initiation aux arts martiaux
objectif détecter les futurs talents
pour cette entreprise l'avis des
salariés à saint quentin en yvelines
fait l'objet d'une enquête dont les
résultats ont été publiés ce mois-ci
nous recevons sur notre plateau deux
invités pour parler de la vie de leurs
collaborateurs et de leurs stratégies de
recrutement
enfin découverte de la plateforme vivre
ou une application destinée aux
entreprises elle permet aux
collaborateurs des sociétés abonnés de
trouver leur logement idéal à proximité
de leur lieu de travail et on accueille
michael praetorius et sofie goos bonsoir
bonsoir
or sofie goos vous et drh du site airbus
à elancourt et me crève croître yeux
vous vous êtes pdg de automation de bill
une pme basée à coignières donc comme je
dire on va parler de la vie de vos
collaborateurs à dans l'entreprise et
puis aussi dans leur vie au quotidien
chez eux mais d'abord le 4 décembre
dernier l'association jazz organisé sa
première soirée des essais mais à paris
donc les essais mais ce sont des
salariés de grandes entreprises qui
s'engagent dans l'entrepreneuriat c'est
le cas d'airbus avec la société au guide
y ans installé à versailles regarder il
était collaborateur dans des grands
groupes ils se sont lancés dans la
création de leur entreprise neuf
entrepreneurs ont été mises à l'honneur
lors d'une soirée le 4 décembre dernier
des créateurs d'entreprises issus de
l'essaimage
le principe les grands groupes
accompagnent leurs salariés dans le
lancement de leurs activités
l'essaimage peut prendre
tous les types de créations
d'entreprises alors certains sont un peu
lié à l'activité initiale groupe mais
pas complètement sinon les laisserait
pas partir et beaucoup peuvent être des
projets de reconversion complète des
gens qui vont se former pour se
reconvertir dans un autre métier
une vingtaine d'entreprises composent
l'association diez organisatrice de cet
événement présente notamment deux
anciens salariés d'airbus à elancourt en
2013 il crée l'entreprise quotidien en
une création d'entreprise accompagnés
par airbus développement leur spécialité
le stockage d'énergie électrique sous
forme d'hydrogène l'hydrogène c'est un
vrai vecteur énergétique et on peut le
produire soi-même en électrisant de haut
donc quand j'ai trop d'énergie au lieu
de le perdre et puis quand mes batteries
sont pleines bas j'en fais quoi je jette
énergie voilà donc là je vais électro
lisais tranquillement de l'aude je vais
mettre du gaz le gaz ou le mettait dans
une bonbonne si elle est en jeu vous
revenez vingt ans après vous avez la
même quantité d'énergie
c'est un but qui est un but sociétale on
accompagne sur le territoire on est
implanté
le développement de l'emploi on ne peut
pas forcément faire nous mêmes c'est de
permettre à des gens de réaliser leurs
rêves qui n'arrivent pas forcément
réalisés dans l'entreprise ça crée de
l'emploi
ça permet de faire du développement
technologique les neuf entreprises
lauréates de la soirée on créer 200
emplois
une initiative innovante pour recruter
localement le site thalès d'elancourt a
organisé jeudi 7 janvier une session de
recrutement autour des arts martiaux au
palais des sports
les candidats et les recruteurs ont pu
découvrir cette discipline de combat
taekwondo au kendo aïkido ou encore
karaté des initiations animé par le budo
club d'elancourt écoutez les réactions
suite à ce rendez vous là je viens de
pratiquer des exercices j'ai trouvé ça
génial d'avoir cette création de
relations au travers d'un apprentissage
en commun il n'y a pas de décalage
y a pas de jeu je sais plus que toi non
on sait pas toutes les deux et on
apprend et on peut échanger l'extension
de sa géniale je pense que ma relation
en tant que manager avec mes
collaborateurs et la confiance que je
leur donne et que leur attribue je
trouve qu'on retrouve cette image là
dans les arts martiaux c'est la relation
de confiance s'est aussi des défis des
défis à relever c'est ce qu'on fait tous
les jours dans thales ça change
énormément du recrutement habituel en
fait ça permet vraiment d'être
décontracté et de voir une autre vision
en fait du recrutement classique as
attractif créatif et complètement
moderne et sa soeur d'ordinaire donc
j'aime bien comment les salariés vivent
le territoire de saint quentin en
yvelines quelles relations entretiennent
ils avec ce dernier
c'est l'objet d'une enquête lancée par
la communauté d'agglomération en octobre
les résultats sont tombés et les
salariés participant attribue la note
moyenne de 14 me sur 20 à cette
collectivité
les détails de cette enquête dans ce
reportage
[Musique]
mesurer le degré de satisfaction des
salariés vis-à-vis de son environnement
de travail
ces audits aussi identifier les besoins
et les attentes des salariés et donc
accroître la tribu de l'attractivité de
saint quentin en yvelines
[Musique]
il ya un 1441 répond dans un territoire
qui est plébiscité par les salariés
notamment par les jeunes cadres qui le
note de 14 et demi sur 20 on s'aperçoit
que c'est un que saint quentin en
yvelines est un territoire à vivre
puisque 15% des salariés souhaiterait
déménager sur une des douze communes de
l'agglomération de saint quentin que 80%
fréquentent les équipements sportifs
culturels et commerces 85% 75% sont un
temps de trajet inférieur à une heure ce
qui satisfait 70% d'entre eux les
principales attentes c'est plutôt au
niveau de la restauration avoir une
offre un petit peu plus variés notamment
sur les circuits courts sur
l'agriculture biologique et avoir une
meilleure connaissance de manière
générale sur tout ce qui se passe sur le
territoire de saint quentin
mais quelle photo russe aux figues ans
on vient de voir les chiffres donc
plusieurs thématiques transport logement
restauration aussi quel regard vous
portez sur ses résultats
votre avis alors effectivement ce sont
des résultats qui sont partagé également
par les salariés du groupe airbus en
particulier le logement est une vraie
attente en particulier pour des profils
tels que les stagiaires ou les apprentis
qui souhaitent se loger sur sur le
territoire et qui ne trouvent pas
forcément à se loger sur le territoire
nous accompagnons aussi les salariés les
candidats que nous recrutons pour qu'ils
puissent s'ils le souhaitent se
rapprocher
du sidel en cours et le logement nous
travaillons régulièrement avec la
communauté d'agglomération pour
renforcer l'offre de transport et
notamment les liaisons directes vers
vers paris il ya une vraie attente aussi
notamment de la jeune génération sur ces
sujets la restauration nous avons la
chance d'avoir un site qui a une offre
variée en termes de restauration donc
peut-être moins concerné par ce cet
aspect là michael praetorius vous êtes
d'autres problématiques parce que c'est
si vous êtes une pme vous êtes combien
de salariés
si on veut être ambitieux broyés en et
10 donc dix salariés sur le site de
coignières comment vivre vos salariés au
quotidien par rapport notamment à ces
problématiques là sur la propreté sur la
problématique logement le problème ne se
pose pas ce que nous au niveau du
recrutement on essaie de recruter locale
donc les gens qui ont le plus de
transports à mon avis doit avoir quelque
chose comme 25 km 25 minutes pardon
transport maximum le plus loin de gérant
salarié oui ils vont être un petit peu
peut-être une commune derrière
rambouillet où aulas au niveau des
clayes-sous-bois voyez donc on est ce
ainsi hier voilà on est sur un triangle
qui est relativement court donc au
niveau du transport le problème se pose
pas véritablement ils sont utilisateurs
de transports en commun où ils viennent
vraiment avec leurs véhicules
individuels les deux en fait il ya des
gens qui viennent en transports en
commun ya des gens qui viennent en
voiture ça dépend complètement
c'est vrai que l' avantage en fonction
with habib sy sont en sens inverse des
embouteillages le matin c'est quand même
beaucoup plus pratique donc il entend
dans ce cas là plutôt prendre le
transport en que les trans le transport
de voitures surtout s'il n'y a pas de
liaison directe qui peuvent avoir des
problèmes de liaison indirects faire les
claies jusqu à coignières c'est un autre
sujet évidemment
donc du coup plutôt voiture mais si vous
venez par exemple de rambouillet ben
vous avez un gars qui est juste à côté
donc il ya vraiment pas de problème de
ce côté là mon vote dans le cas de
michael praetorius et des employés qui
sont qui vivent sur le territoire vous
c'est un peu différent ils viennent
parfois de très loin
notre recrutement de par là
la nature du groupe airbus note
recrutement il est international et les
candidats peuvent venir du territoire et
j'ai perdu du monde entier où la france
entière nous avons dès aujourd'hui des
salariés qui vivent à proximité d'autres
qui vivent plus loin en revanche nous
cherchons à facilités pour ceux qui le
souhaitent
le fait de se rapprocher de déménager et
donc là nous organisons par exemple
régulièrement un forum logement pendant
lequel nous présentons de l'offre de
logements sur le territoire et les
différentes aides qui sont proposés on
parle notamment de la plateforme à vivre
dans un second temps d'abord comment ça
se déroule la vie comment se déroule la
vie des salariés au sein d'entreprises
on voit sur les images a beaucoup
d'activités extra professionnelles
organisées vraiment sur le site d'airbus
à tout à fait notre objectif c'est
vraiment de rendre le site attractif à
la fois pour les talents que nous
recherchons mais aussi pour les salariés
qui travaillent et de créer des lieux
d'échangé de convivialité la vie sur le
site ce sont des activités ça peut des
activités sportives des activités
culturelles
nous avons de nombreux clubs nous avons
une salle de sport des la possibilité de
faire de la musique sur l'heure du
déjeuner ou en fin de journée nous avons
installé sur le site des baby foot et
c'est une vraie attente de la jeune
génération qui souhaitent échanger de
façon plus informelle et pourrait
changer c'est pas forcément derrière
bureau ou dans une salle de réunion mais
ça peut être qu'ils jouent aux cartes
falloir pour certains mais ça peut être
aussi autour d'un baby foot ou dans la
salle de créativité on a créé cet espace
très coloré où il ya des poufs la
possibilité voilà d'échanger de façon un
petit peu différente de faire venir des
start up et de vivre un petit peu ça sa
vie au travail de façon différente
on voit que c'est de bien être au
travail vous michael praetorius
forcément une pme ces plus petits vous
avez quand même une petite espace
détente pour le bien-être de vos
salaires il ya alors quand on parlait
duquel la restauration les gens peuvent
aller dans sur le territoire à côté mais
c'est vrai qu'on a déjà des cuisines
directement sur place pour qu'ils
puissent manger sur place
on n'a pas véritablement de lieux de
détente en termes l'espace important
parce que malheureusement c'est pas
c'est pas le cas et on n'a pas la
possibilité mais après il ya des choses
qui se passe autour
c'est vrai qu'après la problématique est
temps qu'ils sont des gens qui habitent
sur le territoire ils ont tendance
plutôt aller faire leurs loisirs en
dehors du temps de travail
certes il ya les pauses il ya des
possibilités de faire des moments de
distraction mais ça va pas être avec des
activités forcément associative aux
autres parce qu'on n'a pas la taille ni
les moyens de pouvoir les mettre en
place
alors vous en parler de la problématique
du logement l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines s'est associé à une
start up the tree à trac pour développer
l'application vivre ou sur le territoire
un service des ti destinés aux
entreprises et pourtant leurs
collaborateurs objectif trouver leur
logement idéal découverte de cette
plateforme v rod est une application
très simple d'utilisation qui permet aux
salariés de trouver le meilleur lieu
pour son logement
l'objectif est de rapprocher
de réduire les temps de transport et de
rapprocher les habitants emploi c'est un
service qui est mis à la disposition des
entreprises qui est gratuit pour les
entreprises de moins de 50 salariés qui
une participation financière pour les
autres
[Musique]
pour pouvoir définir ces critères on
commence par définir la composition du
foyer
donc par exemple deux adultes mais tant
que nous avons deux enfants
ensuite l'application permet en fonction
des ja de la composition de la famille
de faire une première sélection de
critères par exemple on peut être très
proche de certains services de santé
avoir des écoles à proximité puisque on
a mis des enfants en bas âge accéder
facilement à des commerces après c'est
des questions par rapport au lieu de
travail et le mode de transport et
ensuite quel logement est recherché
ensuite le logiciel agrège toutes les
bases de données et elle va vous faire
des propositions sur les lieux qui sont
plus adaptés en fonction des critères
que vous avez identifié
si vous cliquez sur une des communes qui
a été proposée vous pouvez explorer le
lieu avoir accès à tous les services sur
la commune en particulier sur tout
l'environnement et puis vous avez accès
à toutes les offres des agences
immobilières soin particulier à
particulier soit le bon coin donc toutes
les offres qui correspondent aux
critères demandés
sofie goos vous utiliser cette
plateforme
tout à fait c'est pour nous un vrai
atout pour répondre justement question
des candidats lorsqu'il s'interroge sur
la possibilité de se rapprocher du cid
et l'encours de s'installer à proximité
nous utilisons nous nous appuyons sur
cette plateforme pour justement
convaincre certains candidats de se
rapprocher lorsqu'il le souhaite vous
mettez le croit curieux vous n'avez pas
cette problématique a clairement pas
merci à tous les deux d'être venu sur
notre plateau merci d'être disponible
une date à retenir un jeudi 27 février
prochain saint quentin en yvelines
organise au vélodrome nationale sky
emploi en piste cinq mille offres
d'emploi pour voir durant la journée de
job dating les renseignements
l'inscription sur le site internet qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran
c'est la fin de cette émission merci de
nous avoir suivis et à bientôt sur télé
[Musique]